hello there a very good morning the home
office says a group of detainees armed
with various Weaponry have caused a
disturbance at an immigration removal
center near Heathrow Airport no injuries
have been reported during the unrest at
harmansworth which happened during a
power cut well in a statement a home
office spokesman said there has been a
power outage at harmansworth immigration
removal Center and work is currently
underway to resolve this issue we are
aware of a disturbance at the center and
the appropriate authorities have been
notified and are on scene the welfare
and safety of staff and individuals
detained at harmansworth is our key
priority well let's go straight to our
College product Matthew John Thompson
who joins me now and is there Matthew
what more are you hearing
look details still at this stage are
rather limited but we are hearing
slightly more and starting perhaps to be
able to piece together a little bit more
about what is go going on and what has
gone on as you rightly say the home
office now confirming that essentially
this revolves around detainees who left
their rooms in the center behind me
armed with what the home office has
described as various weaponry and
entered a courtyard inside the center I
understand that the disturbance peaked
at around two o'clock in the morning but
it is still ongoing and obviously it's
serious enough that the
police have been called certainly but
also a group called The National
tactical response group essentially the
the riot squads of the prison service
who've been brought in as well and are
still we understand in the building now
the police say that they were first
called at around quarter to eight in the
evening last night so that shows you
that perhaps this has been ongoing for
some time it's not entirely clear what
the relationship is between the power
cut and the disturbance whether one
calls the other but my information is
that the power cut itself happened
closer to midnight so it's possible that
that is something to do with the
disturbance itself we simply don't know
enough of the detail at this stage one
of the major problems is that this is
essentially as close to a prison complex
as you could possibly imagine it's a
very secure area we're stood on the
outside of it getting limited
information so it's very difficult to be
sure exactly what the out atmosphere is
like on the inside what I would say is
just from watching observing the various
Emergency Services have arrived be they
fire brigade police or whatever there is
not quite a an enormous sense of urgency
in their movement and that perhaps
reflects what my information is that
this peak in the early hours of the
morning but is still ongoing to some
extent quite what extent at this point
we're unable to be exactly sure but as
and when we get more information about
what exactly is going on and whether
it's still going on will of course keep
you updated